En junio de 1998,
Tori Murden McClure zarpó de Nags Head, Carolina del Norte, para Francia.
Ese es su barco, la Perla de América.
Tiene 7 metros de largo y casi 2 metros de ancho
en su punto más ancho.
La cubierta era del tamaño de una camioneta de carga Ford F-150.
Tori la construyó a mano junto con sus amigos
y pesaba unos 820 kg.
Su plan era cruzar remando, sola,
el Océano Atlántico
--sin motor, ni vela--
algo que ninguna mujer y ningún estadounidense nunca había hecho antes.
Esta sería su ruta:
Más de 5790 kilómetros a través del Océano Atlántico Norte.
Tori trabajaba como gerente de proyectos
para la ciudad de Louisville, Kentucky, su ciudad natal,
pero su verdadera pasión era la exploración.
Esta no era su primera gran expedición.
Se había convertido unos años antes
en la primera mujer que llegó esquiando al Polo Sur.
En la universidad fue una deportista en remo con mucho éxito
e incluso compitió por un puesto en el equipo olímpico de Estados Unidos 1992,
pero esto era diferente.
(Video) (Música) Tori Murden McClure: Hola. Es domingo 5 de julio.
Hora local: 9 de la mañana.
La misma que en Kentucky.
Dawn Landes: Tori hizo estos videos mientras remaba.
Este fue tomado en su 11º día en el mar.
Para entonces ya había viajado más de 1600 km,
sin ningún contacto por radio en más de 2 semanas
después de una tormenta que dañó
todos sus sistemas de comunicación de largo alcance
luego apenas de 5 días en alta mar.
La mayoría de los días fue así.
Para entonces, había dado más de 200 000 remadas,
luchando contra la corriente y el viento.
Mientras que otras veces solo avanzaba 4 o 5 metros.
Sí.
Y mientras que aquellos días eran frustrantes,
otros días eran así.
(Video) TMM: Quiero mostrarles a mis amiguitos.
DL: Vio peces, delfines,
ballenas, tiburones,
e incluso algunas tortugas marinas.
Después de 2 semanas sin contacto humano,
Tori pudo comunicarse con un buque de carga local vía radio VHF.
(Video) TMM: ¿Tienen la previsión del tiempo? Cambio.
Hombre: Tienes por delante un área de baja presión,
y ya que obviamente te diriges al noreste,
hay otra de alta presión detrás,
que también parece venir desde el este rumbo al noroeste también.
DMM: Bien.
DL: Estaba muy feliz de hablar con alguien en aquel momento.
(Video) TMM: Así que el pronóstico meteorológico no prevé nada drástico.
DL: Lo que la previsión no mencionaba
era que estaba remando directamente hacia el huracán Danielle,
en la peor temporada de huracanes jamás registrada en el Atlántico Norte.
(Video) TMM: Acabo de torcerme el tobillo.
Hay un viento muy fuerte ahora que viene del este.
Sopla con fuerza.
¡Está soplando!
Después de 12 días de tormenta
pude remar durante 4 horas con viento en calma.
No estoy muy contenta en este momento.
Como lo estuve por la mañana.
No estoy muy feliz ahora, así que...
DL: Después de casi 3 meses en el mar, ha recorrido más de 4800 kilómetros.
Le quedaba solo un tercio del camino,
pero, en la tormenta, las olas tenían una altura de un edificio de 7 pisos.
Su barco volcaba todo el tiempo.
Algunas volcadas eran de punta a punta y por completo,
y era imposible remar.
(Video) TMM: 06:30 de la mañana.
Estoy en medio de algo grande, malo y feo.
Volqué 2 veces.
La última vez arranqué el friso del techo con la espalda.
He volcado unas 6 veces hasta ahora.
La última vez boca abajo.
Tengo la baliza Argos conmigo.
Activaré la señal de socorro,
pero francamente no creo que jamás encontrarán este pequeño barco.
Está muy sumergido en este momento,
la única parte que sobresale del agua es prácticamente la cabina.
Es cerca de las 10 de la mañana,
he perdido la cuenta de cuántas veces he volcado.
Vuelco cada 15 minutos.
Creo que mi brazo izquierdo está roto.
Las olas
están destrozando el barco en pedazos.
Sigo rezando porque no estoy segura de que saldré con vida de esta.
DL: Tori activó la señal de socorro
y fue rescatada por un buque de carga que pasaba por allí.
Encontraron su barco abandonado 2 meses más tarde a la deriva cerca de Francia.
Lo leí en el periódico.
En 1998, yo estudiaba en la secundaria y vivía en Louisville, Kentucky.
Ahora vivo en la ciudad de Nueva York y soy compositora.
Su valentía me llamó la atención
y estoy adaptando su historia para un musical llamado "Remo".
Cuando Tori regresó a su casa, estaba desanimada, arruinada,
y tenía dificultades para reintegrarse en la civilización.
En esta escena, ella está en su casa,
el teléfono llama, sus amigos la están llamando,
pero ella no sabe cómo hablar con ellos
y canta esta canción que se llama "Querido corazón".
(Guitarra)